die gefahr ist real eine äußerst
mysteriöse lungenkrankheit breitet sich
derzeit in china aus jetzt hat sich auch
die weltgesundheitsorganisation whu
eingeschaltet erinnerungen an die
sars-epidemie von 2002 2003 mit etwa 800
todesopfern werden wach oder haben es
hier mit einem neuartigen virus zu tun
das sogar von mensch zu mensch
übertragen wird und damit eine pandemie
auslösen könnte
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und activity glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen heute aus brüssel wo es mich
hin verschlagen hat die lage in der
chinesischen millionenmetropole woran
ist ernst mehr als 200 menschen stehen
unter beobachtung 62 patientinnen und
patienten sind bereits infiziert und
sieben davon befinden sich in einem
kritischen zustand
drei menschen sind an der krankheit
gestorben die betroffenen zeigen
symptome wie fieber und atemprobleme
sie befinden sich in quarantäne das
seltsame lungenleiden wird derzeit als
virale lungenentzündung unbekannter
ursache behandelt noch details sind noch
nicht wirklich bekannt auch nicht wie
gefährlich diese erkrankung ist oder um
eine übertragung von mensch zu mensch
stattfinden kann doch jetzt hat sich
auch die weltgesundheitsorganisation wie
hello eingeschaltet es gibt begrenzte
informationen um das gesamtrisiko dieser
häufung von lungenerkrankungen
unbekannter ursache einzuschätzen bisher
sind noch zitat keine besonderen
vorkehrungen für reisenden vorgesehen
doch die behörden sind aufgeschreckt in
hongkong wurden fieber messgeräte am
flughafen installiert und alle die aus
nur ankommen werden gründlich
kontrolliert die chinesischen behörden
hatten erst vor einigen tagen davon
berichtet dass eine neue krankheit
ausgebrochen ist doch der erste fall
liegt schon länger zurück und wurde
bereits am 12 dezember 2019 registriert
ihren anfang nahm die krankheit wohl auf
einem fischmarkt info haben wo jedoch
nicht nur fische sondern auch andere
tiere gehandelt werden davon geht man
aus weil mehrere der erkrankten auf
diesem fischmarkt gearbeitet hatten
mittlerweile ist der markt geschlossen
alles vor ort wurde gereinigt und
desinfiziert rätselhaft bleibt aber
warum auch ein mädchen in singapur
infiziert ist das kind war zwar in hand
zu gast allerdings nicht auf diesem
markt fest steht das ganze lässt
unschöne erinnerungen an die
sars-epidemie hoch kommt dieses
cute respiratory syndrome nahm 2002
seinen anfang und wird zu den
gefährlichsten infektionswellen jüngster
zeit gezählt die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who hat
insgesamt 8000 saß fälle registriert und
es gab vor etwa 800 todesopfer doch es
hätte und so viel schlimmer treffen
können doch glücklicherweise war dieses
virus nicht so leicht übertragbar wie
beispielsweise die influenza nicht
auszumalen was dann passiert wäre diese
krankheit war aus dem tierreich zu uns
menschen übergesprungen
doch bis heute sind sich fachleute nicht
sicher ob schleichkatzen oder
fledermäuse die ursprünglichen reservoir
wie wirte des virus waren zudem weiteren
beispielen für viren die aus dem
tierreich auf uns menschen
übergesprungen sind zählen ebola märz
tollwut hiv- und influenza in der
fachsprache ist von so genannten zu
losen die rede
das riesige problem dabei ist besteht
die gefahr einer verheerenden epidemie
denn wir menschen haben keine antikörper
gegen solche neuen erreger die spontan
ihren wirt wechseln die chinesischen
behörden aber bestehen darauf dass es
sich bei der mysteriösen lungenkrankheit
weder um die vogelgrippe noch um saas
oder die grippe handelt acht menschen
sind nach polizeiangaben schon
festgenommen worden weil sie zitat
falschaussagen verbreitet hätten
doch auch im internet kursieren wilde
spekulationen ob es sich um einen neuen
saas ausbruch handeln könnte
david haye schien von der universität
hongkong hält das keineswegs für
ausgeschlossen
das virus ist wahrscheinlich für den
menschen ansteckend es könne sich um
eine art corona virus handeln der sars
erreger die menschen in china jedenfalls
sind sehr besorgt denn auch der saas
ausbruch damals wurde von offizieller
seite zunächst verschwiegen fest steht
jedenfalls tödliche viren haben es
heutzutage sehr leicht über die luft und
die atemwege könnte ein virus bis zu 80
millionen menschen töten und das
innerhalb von 36 bis 50 stunden
der ausbruch einer tödlichen pandemie
ist also real das ist das ergebnis einer
gruppe von experten experten des global
preparedness monitoring board emb die
von der weltgesundheitsorganisation who
und der weltbank ins leben gerufen wurde
wir hatten darüber bei clixoom
ausführlich berichtet keime können sich
heutzutage rasend schnell von kontinent
zu kontinent verbreiten der flugverkehr
macht's möglich die
weltgesundheitsorganisation werden
übrigens schon seit 1999 dass sich die
welt auf eine pandemie vorbereiten muss
nach einschätzung der expertin experten
sind es genau sieben wichtige maßnahmen
die politikerinnen und politiker
weltweit jetzt so schnell wie möglich
treffen müssen unter anderem sollten die
investitionen in forschung entwicklung
von impfstoffen erhöht werden aber auch
die vollständige umsetzung der
internationalen gesundheitsvorschriften
sei enorm wichtig zudem wird geraten die
vorbereitung auf eine mögliche pandemie
von allen nationen als einen wichtigen
bestandteil der nationalen und globalen
sicherheit zu werden ebola das tödliche
virus anklicken
die gesamte playlist über die krankheit
von der medizinstudent anschauen und
abonnieren nicht vergessen da erfahrt
ihr eine ziemliche menge über alle
möglichen krankheiten bis dann bleibt
dran